what do you love about this country
I love that it's small
and I love that we existing
and we have to be proud that we have a
country
[Applause]
Kyrgyzstan AKA The kyrgyz Republic is
perhaps not the most obvious place to
visit for a show about technology
foreign
[Music]
used to be part of the Soviet Union
so it has lots of Soviet stuff laying
around
Soviet government buildings
Soviet sculptures
Soviet theme parks with an extra dollop
of wintry dystopia
there's even Vlad the Dead one fresh
from a snowball fight
in the winter the capital city of
bishkak is well it's Bleak coal and
trash fires enveloped the city in smog
it's grim
then beautiful
then grim
then beautiful all over again
and also kind of weird
[Music]
the city's Circus For example takes
place inside a decaying UFO
[Music]
now I'm not going to Dazzle you with the
usual robots in DNA editing
here is about a fragile democracy trying
to find its place in the modern world
our people were so courageous to go and
do the Revolution and fight for it I saw
it they were shooting people
it's about a landlocked Nation one with
very few natural resources hoping to Gin
up a tech industry on the Fly we are
limited by resources I like is that we
don't have a resources otherwise if
everything would be okay so we would be
lazy
Kyrgyzstan it turns out really wants to
sell the rest of the world on its
software engineers and its internet
creators
and on that score they've had at least
one major success
believe it or not some of the most
popular videos on YouTube are cooked up
right here in Bishkek
[Applause]
hello welcome to the billions home let
me show you route
here we make some shoots for our Channel
it is the actors room hello guys hello
[Applause]
Animation Studio A Animation Studio B
welcome to audio recording studio what
up guys hello
I think all our singers are here hello
a man who got 2.5 billion views
everybody knows these guys everybody
knows this guy is in Kazakhstan to be
the part of this team there's a Dream
Team really
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie
I came here in small part to kind of
make fun of the billions
good job
it's a kids show on YouTube and if you
have spawn there's a very good chance
they have consumed some of this
it's not exactly High art
some people might even call it
villainous ear poison
[Music]
but whatever you think doesn't really
matter
they get the views the billions and to
billions of them this is our diamond
button first in Central Asia this is our
trophy we achieve it that we get 10
million subscribers
how did a 50-person outfit in a country
many people have never heard of achieve
this kind of success
to find out I sat down with the founders
husband and wife team Ernest and chopani
Ernest is a producer and chopani is a
singer and actor I do this
for a living you know research people
there's just there's like nothing about
you guys the Western press has not sort
of
it's gonna be first interview this one
okay
okay for people who have never seen any
of your shows before can you explain
what the billions is
a
we have 13 channels on in different
languages in the the two of you you're a
husband and wife right and we grew up
together studying uh studying in seat or
Children's Choir that's called akshola
we took part in many International kids
festivals and when Ernest was 15 years
old he created teenage group we were
wrapping break dancing singing classic
songs pop songs that was the beginning
of the billions
we had all the experience we needed to
work on YouTube
we have four music video with billion
views and in addition when we first saw
the baby shark video it already had
billion views
Ernest said I also can make such a song
[Music]
Here's how that went
so what's the secret sauce I like it I
like it I think kids loves the reason of
the song like
yummy
kids loves to repeat it and there is one
more secret it's in minimalism I am a
triangle I am a triangle every uh song
has a goal to teach one or two words
without overloading kids attention
[Music]
statistics show that the most minimalist
songs break all records you heard our
internet creators now go get those
debilions
okay so maybe it's not the most
mind-improving content
but it is some kind of modern phenomenon
the billions is just one of a dozen
channels this company is feeding
and their success has allowed them to
recruit the best singers graphic artists
and composers in the country all to pump
out videos at Hyper Speed this is a very
American crass question how big is the
business in terms of not just viewers
but it must be like huge in terms of
Revenue companies
[Music]
Ernest didn't want to get into exact
numbers
so let's take a wild guess shall we
other YouTube kids channels with similar
view counts have reported earning
Millions even tens of millions of
dollars per year
the billions might take a hit from
having many viewers outside the U.S but
it's safe to say they're doing well for
themselves
the whole Enterprise gets a boost from
the kirga's government in Industry too
through a program called it Park the
hope is to conjure a flourishing kyrgys
tech industry out of thin air by giving
companies like debilians massive tax
breaks participants of IIT Park they are
free from all Texas except one percent
income tax and we are participants of 80
Park and that's been a great sport from
our government
thank you
but the picture wasn't always this Rosy
for debilions
virality might come easy to these folks
but trying to get paid on YouTube that's
a whole other thing
before the debilis there was a channel
Ewa AWA AWA and we're working there and
we got one hit cartoon it was so 42
million views that was for us phenomenal
I would kill for 42.
you oh my God that was we unbelief that
moment was for us like the phenomenal
yeah to say like wow a video so 42
million see
but then and then
they cut almost in the monetization
and we didn't get any uh YouTube money
yeah
demonization
we didn't know some rules okay that's
why nobody will tell us okay
Stephen what we should to do
we were working two years just for free
okay yeah it was very hard time
so it was it sounds like it was sort of
frightening for what like scary yeah
yeah so you you yes you were a couple
with a young child and taking all this
Financial Risk money no
[Laughter]
[Music]
I may have come here to tease but my
time with the devillians crew left me
amazed
the vibe at the office was more
hard-working fun-loving family than more
on-filled influencer mansion
and there was creativity everywhere
[Music]
boom boom can play basically any
instrument
[Music]
Ernest and chopini have an obvious eye
for talent and a gift for reading the
whims of the internet
and instead of staff meetings the
billions has all hands campfire
sing-alongs
[Applause]
hey
it was just a small warm-up before the
shooting our cartoons
of course to really understand the
billions
[Applause]
to become the billion
[Music]
behold American Daddy
savior of YouTube children
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm about to be a superhero in a
debilians video you go to Kyrgyzstan and
amazing things happen
ing up okay this site okay I'm super dad
people are in trouble I must save them
are you ready yeah Camera Action
s
oh don't worry don't worry
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for teaching me to be a
superhero
all right now I want to see that I want
to see the professionals work
is
[Applause]
civilians told me they would animate
this all together into something amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
in the meantime allow me to tell you
some less kid-friendly things about the
kyrgyz Republic
[Applause]
the country became part of the Soviet
Union in 1936.
the Soviets did their best to try and
turn a rural very poor Society into
something else
mostly they poured money into Bishkek in
the buildings and people followed
the kyrgyz Republic arrived in 1991.
it's a democracy but not exactly a grade
a democracy votes can be bought and sold
and there's a not infrequent number of
coups
it's a Muslim Nation but religion does
not feel like it takes Center Stage here
today the country's ties to Russia
remain strong with cheap energy meant to
keep the kyrgyz people sweet it's a
precarious position and one from which
many people here hope to break free
the billions is meant to represent what
Kyrgyzstan can be in the future
a more Modern Nation one full of
creativity and expression
[Music]
but this journey is not always smooth
take for example the story of zere
[Music]
bus singers in the country
she's YouTube famous too but in a very
different way
started thinking okay I should do
something big something about women's
rights because that's what I care about
deeply right now
[Music]
started writing a song
I made my friends listen to it they said
maybe I should do a video so that's how
it all started and you did go viral I
did I guess yeah
foreign
[Music]
obviously the lyrics of the song brought
up a lot of issues
um that some people were you know happy
very happy to see being discussed openly
and obviously a lot of people were less
happy and then in the video I think you
were wearing a bra and people were you
know what happened so the reaction was
basically enormous I thought that the
provoking stuff would be seeing like a
girl in hijab besides a girl in a bikini
and you know all of that diversity that
has never been seen before but the
provoking thing was something that I
literally just decided like in a second
you know I was like okay I'm gonna look
like this that was the main trigger for
the whole dialogue to start I was sort
of ready for some backlash sort of ready
for some you know bullying or stuff like
that but uh it always seems easy in
theory but I think you got death threats
and I did I did get death threats and uh
there were a lot of them actually do you
still face a lot of the pushback or has
it sort of died down like is it
uncomfortable for you to walk down the
street I wouldn't say I'm comfortable
walking in any Street like a terrible
example yeah because because I've heard
you say about this yeah yeah like on top
of the cat calling and everything that
you get as a woman if you're also like a
feminist who was naked on the screen and
all of that and that also puts other
layers you know
it can be
[Music]
part of the reaction was how you were
dressed the part of the reaction was the
things you were talking about and the
stories I read just said these are
things that aren't often discussed well
um I think they were always discussed
not just collectively like that you know
not through one thing that everyone has
an opinion on how would you describe the
issues that women face broadly
for an average woman in Kyrgyzstan
it's hard everywhere like at home in the
streets you can literally get kidnapped
like and made a bride you're supposed to
marry your rapist basically when you get
kidnapped as a bride unfortunately it
still happens it doesn't happen as often
as you know before but still it does
happen
Kyrgyzstan is bizarrely famous or rather
Infamous for the practice of bride
kidnapping women are grabbed off the
streets and forced into marriage
no one in the country seems to agree on
how prevalent this is although in my
short time here I met several women who
told me they had been kidnapped or had
family members who had been kidnapped
the practice was only made illegal a
couple of years ago and it's
questionable how much the law is
actually enforced if a woman gets
harassed beaten up at home assaulted in
the streets and a lot of other stuff
that can happen to women you go to the
police police is never going to help you
I've never seen one case in my life
where the police was actually helpful in
these issues
we asked the kyrgyz government to
comment on all this but we never heard
back
and can I just ask that I'm saying this
absolutely like being in love with this
country you know what I mean like it's
not like I'm complaining and like trying
to go somewhere no like I wanna be among
those people who try and make Kyrgyzstan
at least like a safer place to live
[Laughter]
[Music]
is there a sense that things are are
changing if I looked there was a female
president relatively recently I think
the first in Central Asia their sense
that things are changing or like do you
feel like it's just the same as it ever
was I myself I I'm very amazed and
inspired by a lot of what women do in
our country
[Music]
and you're right like relatively
speaking in the region where we are we
have some better stuff going on but
that's but that's relatively speaking
you know
there's a lot still to do yeah for sure
[Music]
the next night the devillians crew
invites me out for an evening of revelry
fish cake Style
[Applause]
[Music]
after getting good and Tipsy on kyrgy's
lager
[Applause]
I'm for the grand unveiling
as exciting as it gets I get to see
myself as USA Super Daddy on on a big
screen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
there's every chance to billions is a
one-off they got lucky hitting the
internet just right
but Kyrgyzstan is betting and hoping
that this is the start of a full-on tech
Revolution within the country
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the woman riding this horse so
majestically is tavida
[Music]
and she symbolizes a lot about
Kyrgyzstan
this is a place where the people take
great pride in the natural beauty of the
country
it's also a place fond of its traditions
and nomadic past
tavita though is also part of something
new and different here
when not galloping
she's coding
foreign
[Music]
she's part of a wave of thousands of
young kyrga students being trained as
software engineers
the hope is to create a homegrown
curious tech industry which can serve as
an economic engine to power the
country's future
[Music]
naturally I went to a fine dining yurt
with tevita and her sister Abigail who
also works in Tech to learn more about
their experiences
what do we have so different kinds of
bread and boar sock it's like fried
dough it smells good yeah these are the
different types of meat and horse meat
as well okay how did the two of you get
into technology because you both have
interest obviously so my sister first
started interested in Native sphere and
after that she said she'd recommend me
to get into the I.T industry what have
you been doing
developer
what kind of company meanwhile tavita's
Sister Abigail has a job telling the
world about kyrgyzstan's coding efforts
if you want to work with American Tech
communities businesses you have to have
provide really high quality so our pitch
was that we've been working we are
experience we already have clients and
also cheap infrastructure like
electricity and also demographics very
young people there are a lot of talents
and I think that this is because there
was like huge focus on mathematics and
people are being just very motivated
it's a pretty convincing story which is
good because the stakes are high
Kyrgyzstan has a nearly 30 percent
poverty rate
per capita GDP only a mother could love
with few natural resources to mine and
little in the way of Big Industry it
needs to look outside the goal for the
country is to have how many programmers
fifty thousand fifty thousand by 2030 by
2030 and what number are we at today
um I think around seven thousand seven
thousand all right so you're part of
like the seven thousand though yeah
to build a fifty thousand strong
software Army you need boot camps
this is the headquarters of codify one
of several companies in Bishkek with
coding programs for people of all ages
it was started by Dinara ruslin she grew
up here moved to Silicon Valley and then
came back with the hopes of building a
Tech Giant in Bishkek I was doing like
it project product management and I
always needed project managers but I
couldn't get them because no one
actually prepares them here in Central
Asia so then I started teaching it
myself you have this fascinating
background because you you worked in
Silicon Valley and Technology I saw you
worked in Iowa in technology and I mean
for you to come back and do this you
must have some hope that you can help in
this position to sort of modernize
whereas this you just saw a business
opportunity you know like when you grew
up in the family where you like low
income low-class family you just don't
think on like oh my God I'm gonna help
my country know you're thinking like oh
my God what I'm gonna eat tomorrow I'm
gonna survive you know so I I'm gonna
lie if I say oh oh I want to you know
like help the country whatever I know I
grew up thinking that I have to become
someone
[Music]
Dinara did become someone a product
manager at Wells Fargo
tasted the decadent Delights that the
magical land of California has to offer
you get a job and you are making money
and you start you know going to mall on
weekends and then to cinema on Fridays
with your friends and then you think oh
my God this is the life this is the
American dream I was like taking Uber
and then I was buying and I'm ordering
this weekly you know vegetables to be
delivered to my house you know but then
it snapped it was May 2016.
I was thinking I haven't seen my family
in
in my country in four years
I just decided to took a vacation and
then I was supposed to leave to go back
to my another dream job in California
and then I got this job offer from local
startup
tanara never left and eventually started
several companies of her own
might frame her decision to stay as
strictly business but her coding school
is very much part of the national
project preparing little ones to
participate in the economy of the future
the um
my name is Lee I'm 15 and I study HTML
my name is Ladonna I'm 16 years old and
I'm studying here at JavaScript
ARA takes particular
opening young women become tech savvy if
you look at the I.T scene if you even
look at my office 80 of the girls you're
gonna see other startup Founders they're
also like female Founders so you will
see that the curbison is different
it's a happy fact that women have a
strong presence in the kyrgyz tech scene
I met a good number of female leaders
and Engineers during my visit to Bishkek
they're not hard to find
but the picture is complicated
Society can be brutally chauvinistic
women are often expected to take on
traditional roles in the home not to
learn to code or pursue a career
society's opinion will affect you if you
think about it
if you don't think about it then just
study and do your job
like who cares what that person is
saying that you can or cannot do if you
think if you believe that you can do
something
that's all that matters when it comes to
women's issues Dinara is quick to
accentuate the positive and insist that
anyone can make it
but that's no surprise coming from a
self-made woman who founded three
companies by the age of 30.
if anyone can bootstrap Kyrgyzstan into
Tech prosperity
it's people like her do you have a
future yes
is it bright one I think yes because I'm
a dreamer I actually have a dream to
build a first unicorn out of
Kyrgyzstan and Central Asia hopefully
qualify
I for one wouldn't bet against her
[Music]
don't go to Kyrgyzstan in the winter
they told me
it's gray and polluted
it's a horrible time to visit they said
how else would I have seen this
it's time in a kyrgyz village about
three hours from Bishkek
you get a goat
the goat suffers
and then you have what amounts to a ball
thank you
and whoever has the ball is under attack
[Music]
[Applause]
the goal on this day is to get the goat
back to your village first
[Music]
it's been well tenderized
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
clearly this is a place that keeps its
Traditions alive
at least the super epic ones
but kyrgyzstan's future is taking shape
out here too so that's why I'm lucky
Mouser then that's thanks in large part
to this extremely cheerful man
if
made a fortune in the biotech business
all over the world then came back to
Kyrgyzstan in hopes of making his
homeland more prosperous and free
set out to build a series of schools
throughout the country
the first one came to life here where he
grew up we're going to your school yeah
it's a first school because we built it
in 10 years ago 11 years ago for school
and how close is it to where you went to
school I grew up on the village on this
Village but I always been working from
this Village until that Village okay two
miles every day you walk two miles in
the snow it was a classic
classical story
here we go
[Music]
oh wow
this music time it looks like
[Music]
it's always the best time music yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
this one it's all local flora fauna okay
which we have in Kyrgyzstan okay
[Music]
philando wants his schools to Foster
creative and critical thinking in
contrast to what he sees as the more
rote instruction at government schools
he's built 15 schools across Kyrgyzstan
plans to build 15 more
he's funded much of this operation to
date but hopes the schools will soon be
self-sustaining
[Music]
tell me about your whole whole vision of
how you started the schools and where
you want to take it it's a simple what
for you you need money
money should work with something so
that's why I had the first ideas that I
have to have attend schools I will have
a one million dollars for one school
every year and then I said okay I now I
have to find a business which will
generate enough money to build the
schools for me
[Applause]
talundu is a teenager when the Soviet
Union collapsed in 1991 leaving
kyrgyzstan's economy in shambles
he was able to get a medical degree in
Bishkek and took a job in the government
but quickly found himself at a dead end
for me it was on front of mine it's a
two-way
Isaac have to corrupt it
either have to poor so you thought if
you stay at the government you're and
you just do your job and you do it well
you're going to be poor because I think
you said yeah because my salary was that
time that time it was 50 bucks a month
so I decided to start my business but
while I am from the village and I don't
have a relatives who can help for me and
so I decided what I can do I can sell my
brain only and so I decided to to build
IT consulting company
[Music]
Medical Diagnostic business
put in by medical diagnostics from this
man
and tell me everywhere you have a
Diagnostic lab now it's Kazakhstan
Kyrgyzstan Ukraine yeah Ukraine Russia
before in China in Vietnam this has
turned into a massive business yes some
kind of enough to build the schools yeah
foreign
you want all these kids to be able to
participate in the global Academy
absolutely so that's why it's a 80
percent of our students our schools are
entering the best universities in U.S
and Europe that doesn't bother you that
they're going overseas you feel like I
believe that some some of them they will
stay in there in U.S or Europe but I
believe some of them they will come back
and I believe that critical mass of that
people will change country
hi guys how are you doing
be cool guys
would be nice to support can we join for
you for discussion for your debate yeah
yeah it's good
we happened to visit to London school on
a very special day
got a debate going on it's uh 10th and
11th grade students I think it's it's
kind of should art be taught in schools
and we've got we've got Pro arts and
we've got the the cruel anti-art people
Prince Harmony
and science given the students the
opportunity to better understand how and
why things work
sat back and watched the free thinking
fly learning to read through the music
up to develop our brain and increase our
Mental Health
from Dead Poets Society if the students
were also being stunningly eloquent in
their third language providing their
Arts adequately is part of the
curriculum cost
and sources I urge you to support our
position the art isn't essential to be
in the school today
yeah
I think it would be nice to just to
listen to your position on Parliament
actually well I thought both sides made
good arguments I am a reporter and a TV
maker who who covers Science and
Technology but I'm making arts about
science and technology so I think we
can't have them split we have to have
both together
from my position
I I take the simple things do you know
what this means guys I believe that 75
of this is Art and mostly I think it's a
without linkage between art and and the
technology you should you couldn't
create new new exciting things in the
world
[Music]
try to know how optimistic to feel about
kirika said it still seems like you have
some of these fundamental problems that
there's limited natural resources
there's people like you that are trying
to educate students and there's people
pushing in technology but it's going to
be a long journey
yeah it can be a long journey yeah but
we are lucky that we don't have a
mineral resources we are lucky that we
don't have a oils okay and all of
situations pushing us to think more what
we can do what we can achieve because
I I see some kind of countries who has a
for example oil
and they're becoming lazy
because it's easy to take oil and salt
it it's easy if you uh depends only on a
human being then it's a question then
it's starting to move
[Music]
back in Bishkek there are signs that
many things in Kyrgyzstan are changing
and changing for the better
[Music]
this building may not look like much
from the outside
in fact it looks pretty terrible
but on the inside there's a group of
young women aiming for the Stars
or at least for low earth orbit
kizji back here is the director of the
kyrgyz Space Program aka the satellite
building School for Girls
thank you the goal is to make
kyrgyzstan's first satellite and fly it
into space
unfortunately with the collapse of the
USSR we do not have any space projects
or no space agencies so that's what we
are trying to do to revive this industry
and we are also doing it with a team of
girls because we really want to convey
our message that we need more girls in
stamps in technology
[Music]
so this is the first satellite in our
country that we brought here
it's a big reveal
this is a prototype of a cubesat of
course you don't want this to go to
space because it's not really protected
and doesn't use the materials that are
able to endure space but it's a great
model to learn with yeah and if I can
nerd out for a second because I'm a
satellite nerd not too long ago if you
wanted to build satellite you have to do
everything from scratch it was very
expensive it was like Reinventing the
wheel every time
[Music]
and then a couple universities in the
United States came up with this cubesat
idea to sort of standardize the shape
some of the components you could put in
and so this is just a really cool thing
where it gives you this huge Head Start
it pulls the price down yes that's
totally true even the 30 years ago we
would not have imagined we would be able
to do that and now you can see space is
successful it's open to everyone yeah
it's great totally take a nation state
to do this yeah so basically the idea
was to understand what components does
the cubesat consist from how they
communicate with each other how they
work with each other
and try to connect them to our own
sensor
when people ask us what is your
satellite going to do in space
we say you know it doesn't matter what
it is doing in space it's going to be
the first satellite of our country yeah
in space it will we will have some space
Heritage will have knowledge expertise
that we can transfer to an educational
institution you know to promote space
and to revive the industry
[Music]
if ever there's been a time when this
plan could work it's right now
with tiny starter satellites available
for purchase and Commercial rocket
companies selling ever more affordable
flights into orbit there's never been an
easier time to get your Gadget off
planet
that doesn't mean it's trivial
kissimback still needs to raise a few
hundred grand to get a spot on a SpaceX
a rocket lab launch
and it's always a dicey proposition
whether these things will actually work
once they're exposed to the void so you
need some money and you still have some
work to do I mean you have a goal date
to fly the satellite oh that's the
toughest one I tell people that if I
were paid a dollar each time a person
knows this question we have to embrace
what people do in space which is you
just announce that they and they're just
really late that's what everybody does
you know that's the it's the beauty of
it yeah
foreign
the team succeeds they'll give birth to
a kyrgyz space industry
even more important they'll send an
undeniable message to the haters and
losers who don't think women have a
place in kyrgyzstan's Tech future they
see I think women of my kind of a danger
they are scared and they say you know
you have I'm not sure that it's supposed
to be on the camera like you have balls
why do you compare me to a man why am I
supposed to have balls I don't like this
trend well if you are a cool woman
you're compared to a man
therefore I think for us as Role Models
it's not only important to become role
models in stem but also in personal life
saying that I am a strong woman I can do
everything and that's why my personal
life and my career you know I can excel
in them they can both work out together
I didn't have a lot of expectations
coming here but even if you just spend a
week in Kyrgyzstan there's some things
that become totally obvious
it's a beautiful country
[Music]
the people must be among the most
generous in the world
[Applause]
and it's a country that's fragile in a
delicate state but one where there's a
lot of Hope for the future
and Anything Could Happen
[Music]